sabrina spellman is back to raise hell
in greendale and uncovered the secret
truth about herself in part two of her
chilling adventures
yippie kaye movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm explaining everything you
need to know about the second season of
chilling adventures of sabrina the
hidden clues you missed in the episode
finale and what to look forward to in
season three
of course there'll be spoilers so take
care if you're not all caught up
the second season of chilling adventures
finally reveals sabrina's true parentage
as she goes to confront lucifer who's
risen from hell into greendale he
reveals that he the dark lord is
sabrina's father
it's a darth vader-esque moment as
sabrina learns her real father is the
big bad and she's not the half-witch
half-mortal she always thought she was
sabrina's conception and birth were a
twist on the biblical story of mary and
joseph where it was the holy spirit
not joseph who conceived the baby jesus
in mary
biblical references abound throughout
this season with the first episode
starting with a dream sabrina has of her
birth which is reminiscent of
traditional christian nativity scenes
the episode is called the epiphany with
the three kings of hell an obvious play
on the three wise men or kings who visit
jesus
as ambrose explains in the finale the
dark lord's plan
in siring a babe of a witch mortal and
infernal blood is to pervert the holy
trinity
before this revelation incredible powers
that sabrina never knew she had are
gradually unveiled
in the sixth episode during the witch
hunters attack they placed a crown of
thorns on her head
and peers her body three times with
crossbow arrows evoking parallels with
christ's crucifixion
sabrina dies but is resurrected like
christ and then as she levitates with
hands ablaze she sets the witch hunters
on fire in a scene that reminded me of
the end of the first season when sabrina
summoned hellfire against the greendale
13
becoming only the fourth witch in
history to ever achieve that
she's even able to resurrect melvin and
elsbeth who the witch hunters had
murdered
you're not a witch what are you i am
the dark lord's sword
from sabrina's words it's clear that
these amazing powers stem from her
infernal blood or conception by the dark
lord
harvey also points out to sabrina that
she resembles jean grey with her phoenix
powers in this scene
jean grey was this really powerful
mutant
when she was on the verge of death
something saved her like sabrina when
jean grey had access to the phoenix
force her power levels went insane
and there were even instances where the
force brought the dead back to life
these miracles were explored in more
detail in the seventh episode with
further parallels being drawn between
sabrina and jesus
sabrina restores roz's sight by getting
her to wash her eyes in a miracle not
dissimilar to how jesus gave sight to a
blind man when he ordered him to go wash
in a pool of water
sabrina's devilish dna seems to give her
powers unavailable to her witch brethren
and initially in her often impetuous way
she assumes there's no downside
to these almost unlimited abilities much
to the consternation of her aunt hilda
everything has a price that's how
witchcraft works but i don't think
there's a price for me oh
not anymore i think i've tapped into a
different kind of magic
one that isn't based on cause and effect
it feels
different you are racking up a cosmic
debt the like of which the world has
never seen
as sabrina's friends later discover her
display of extraordinary powers is
actually a harbinger of a dreadful
future
the mosaic they discover in the
greendale mines shows that the dark lord
plans for sabrina to be the herald of
hell in other words the bringer of the
apocalypse
after lucifer arrives in greendale he
orders sabrina to blow the horn of
gabriel and open
the gates of hell so the vips of the
underworld can attend her coronation as
their queen
lilith who has served the dark lord all
this time in the belief that she would
be the one ascending to the throne
decides she's fed up of being constantly
cast aside by lucifer
we do see a slightly softer side to
madame satan this season when she meets
miss wardwell's boyfriend adam and
discovers the possibility of a loving
relationship
but when the dark lord finds out about
lilith's secret relationship he cruelly
kills adam and serves him up on a
platter
so by the time of the finale when
lucifer rejects lilith again
she decides to team up with sabrina and
the spelmans to defeat the dark lord
after a failed attempt to kill lucifer
in the woods they concoct a different
scheme to entrap him in the acharon
configuration that held the sleep demon
batty bat
sabrina and the coven put on a
masquerade dance and sabrina then
captures lucifer and edward spellman's
acheron
however it doesn't hold for long and the
devil breaks out
when lilith explains that the only
prison stronger than the acheron is a
human body
nick scratch offers himself as a host
body to keep lucifer imprisoned
nick who studied edward's teaching says
he's the best binder and conjurer since
edward spellman and believes he's the
only one
strong enough to contain the devil and
so nick's scratch becomes the devil
himself something that's always been
hinted at in his name as old nick and
old scratch and nicknames for the devil
nick's actions are also a way for him to
redeem himself for secretly betraying
sabrina to the dark lord
by the way a nice detail in this scene
and episode is the name of the dance
that sabrina and lucifer perform at the
masquerade
the mephisto waltz which is also the
name of a 1971 horror movie about
satanists and body swapping
and after lucifer is defeated lilith
finally gets the job she's been wanting
forever
queen of hell she takes nick's body down
with her to make sure lucifer doesn't
escape
before she leaves though she restores
sabrina's witch abilities
so now my dear you have both power and
freedom
and may you never give up either again
however it's unclear at this point if
these include the full powers we saw on
display that came from her infernal
heritage
or if it's just regular witch powers
chaos season 2
doesn't just overturn the established
order in the underworld
when lucifer meets with father blackwood
the dark lord mocks the new church of
judas that blackwood has imposed on the
greendale coven
in fact lucifer orders blackwood to bow
down to sabrina telling him his church
must report to her
blackwood is furious as he knows that
sabrina is opposed to the misogynist and
regressive rules he's enforced in the
church
plus he also plotted to kill sabrina and
her family including ambrose
blackwood is so enraged that rather than
hand power over the coven to sabrina
he poisons them all except his daughter
prudence and his twins
prudence is horrified by this and his
plans to continue the blackwood line by
marrying his twins to each other
and with the help of the spelmans they
managed to save agatha dorcas and some
of the other witches and warlocks
we also discovered this season as many
of us already suspected that blackwood
was responsible for engineering the
plane crash that killed edward and diana
spellman
the irony for blackwood is that despite
his efforts to block edward spellman's
reforms one of the tenets from his
manifesto has now become a reality that
all witches must be revered as the
matriarchs of the church of night
so with blackwood's departure zelda has
now become the church's high priestess
blackwood's future looks bleak with
eventual prudence and ambrose ready to
hunt him down next season with swords
and crossbows
signaling that blackwood's reign over
their church is over prudence
decapitates the judas statue he
installed at the academy
possibly also foreshadowing her father's
eventual fate
i also wonder whether there'll be any
long lasting effects from the ringering
of roses incantations that the weird
sisters were performing
in modern times the traditional rhyming
song has been associated with the plague
and we did briefly see blackwood's nose
bleeding while the sisters were singing
it
whether there'll be any lasting ill
effects on blackwood though remains to
be seen
with sabrina clearer about her origins
and future now she's much freer to spend
more time with her mortal friends harvey
ross and theo who are often off doing
their own thing by themselves in part
two
in fact sabrina recognises that the trio
managed to keep the demonic hordes at
bay by themselves when they held the
gates of hell closed so she realizes she
doesn't need to protect
them all the time indeed sabrina
suggests they team up for what harvey
calls the fright club and sabrina comes
up with their first mission which is to
go to hell and bring nick back
now that sounds like it could be fun but
it seems pretty likely that something
will go
wrong and lucifer will end up escaping
and although lilith has gone to hell
thankfully we'll still be seeing actress
michelle gomez on the show as the
original ms wardwell is back so we'll be
finding out if she suffered any side
effects from lilith inhabiting her body
sabrina also mentioned she's going to
look into her mother's side of the
family
that could be really interesting
especially if the other baby we saw at
sabrina's birth
isn't just symbolic of her jewel nature
but is actually a secret twin
until we find out i've got a theory
video on all the possibilities which you
should check out by tapping in the top
right or click the link in the video
description
so what did you think of sabrina season
2 and do you have any theories or ideas
on what you'd like to see next season
leave your thoughts in the comments
below for more deep dives like this into
your favorite tv shows subscribe and hit
the bell to get all my new videos
if you enjoyed this tap left to watch my
sabrina twin theory video
or tap right for another video you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yippie kai movie lovers